there was an article called the Twitter
files which is about these files that
were released once Elon took control of
Twitter and he released internal
documents and the what happened was
somebody nominated it for deletion but
even the nomination said
this is actually
this is mainly about the hunter Biden
laptop controversy shouldn't this
information be there instead so anyone
can like it takes exactly one human
being anywhere on the planet to propose
something for deletion and that triggers
a process where people discuss it which
within a few hours it was what we call
snowball closed I.E this doesn't have a
snowball's chance and Hell of of passing
so an admin goes yeah wrong and closed
the debate and that was it that was the
whole thing that happened
um and so nobody proposed suppressing
the information nobody suppose it wasn't
important it was just like editorially
boring internal question
and you know so sometimes people read
stuff like that and they're like oh you
see look at these leftists they're
trying to suppress the truth again it's
like well slow down a second and come
and look like literally it's not what
happened
yes I think the right is more sensitive
to censorship
uh and so yeah they will more likely
uh highlight there's more virality to
highlighting something that looks like
censorship in any walks of life and this
moving a paragraph from one place don't
know they're removing it it's on as part
of the regular grappling of Wikipedia
can make a hell of a good article a
YouTube video yeah yeah yeah so it
sounds really uh enticing and intriguing
and surprising to most people because
they're like
I'm reading Wikipedia it doesn't seem
like a crackpot leftist website it seems
pretty
kind of dull really and it's on geeky
way well so that makes a good story it's
like oh am I being misled because
there's a shadowy cabal of Jimmy Wales